- [Instructor] We are told
a restaurant owner installed
a new automated drink machine.
The machine is designed to
dispense 530 milliliters
of liquid on the medium size setting.
The owner suspects that the
machine may be dispensing
too much in medium drinks.
They decide to take a
sample of 30 medium drinks
to see if the average amount
is significantly greater
than 500 milliliters.
What are appropriate hypotheses for their
significance test?
And they actually give
us four choices here.
I'll scroll down a little
bit so that you can see
all of the choices.
So like always, pause
this video and see if you
can have a go at it.
Okay now let's do this together.
So let's just remind ourselves
what a null hypothesis is
and what an alternative hypothesis is.
One way to view a null hypothesis,
this is the hypothesis where
things are happening as expected.
Sometimes people will describe this
as the no difference hypothesis.
It'll often have a
statement of equality where
the population parameter
is equal to a value
where the value is what
people were kind of assuming all along.
The alternative hypothesis,
this is a claim where if you have evidence
to back up that claim,
that would be new news.
You are saying hey there's
something interesting
going on here.
There is a difference.
And so in this context,
the no difference,
we would say the null hypothesis would be,
we would care about the
population parameter,
and here we care about the
average amount of drink
dispensed in the medium setting.
So the population parameter
there would be the mean,
and that the mean would be
equal to 530 milliliters.
Because that's what the drink
machine is supposed to do.
And then the alternative hypothesis,
this is what the owner fears,
is that the mean actually
might be larger than that,
larger than 530 milliliters.
And so let's see which
of these choices is this?
Well these first two choices
are talking about proportion,
but it's really the average
amount that we're talking about.
We see it up here.
They decide to take a
sample of 30 medium drinks
to see if the average amount,
they're not talking
about proportions here,
they're talking about averages,
and in this case we're
talking about estimating
the population parameter,
the population mean,
for how much drink is
dispensed on that setting.
And so this one is looking
like this right over here.
Only these two are even
dealing with the mean.
And the difference between
this one and this one
is this says the mean is
greater than 530 milliliters,
and that indeed is the owner's fear.
And this over here, this
alternative hypothesis,
is that the, that it's
dispensing on average
less than 530 milliliters,
but that's not what
the owner is afraid of.
And so that's not the kind of the news
that we're trying to
find some evidence for.
So I would definitely pick choice C.
Let's do another example.
The National Sleep Foundation recommends
that teenagers aged 14 to 17 years old
get at least eight
hours of sleep per night
for proper health and wellness.
A statistics class at a
large high school suspects
that students at their school are getting
less than eight hours of sleep on average.
To test their theory,
they randomly sample 42 of these students
and ask them how many hours
of sleep they get per night.
The mean from this sample,
the mean from the sample,
is 7.5 hours.
Here's their alternative hypothesis.
The average amount of sleep
students at their school get
per night is...
What is an appropriate ending
to their alternative hypothesis?
So pause this video and see
if you can think about that.
So let's just first think
about a good null hypothesis.
So the null hypothesis is,
hey there's actually no news here,
that everything is what
people were always assuming.
And so the null hypothesis
here is that no,
the students are getting
at least eight hours
of sleep per night.
And so that would be,
that remember we care about
the population of students.
And so and we care about
the population of students
at the school.
And so we would say
well the null hypothesis
is that the parameter for
the students at that school,
the mean amount of sleep
that they're getting,
is indeed greater than
or equal to eight hours.
And a good clue for the
alternative hypothesis
is when you see something
like this where they say,
a statistics class at a
large high school suspects,
so they suspect that
things might be different
than what people have always been assuming
or actually what's good for students.
And so they suspect that
students at their school
are getting less than eight
hours of sleep on average.
And so they suspect that
the population parameter,
the population mean, for
their school is actually
less than eight hours.
And so if you wanted to write this
out in words,
the average amount of sleep
students at their school get
per night is less
than eight hours.
Now one thing to watch out for is one,
you wanna make sure you're
getting the right parameter.
Sometimes it's often a population mean.
Sometimes it's a population proportion.
But the other thing that sometimes
folks get stuck up on,
but the other thing that
sometimes confuses folks is,
well we are measuring,
is that we are calculating a statistic
from a sample.
Here we're calculating the sample mean,
but that, the sample
statistics are not what
should be involved in your hypotheses.
Your hypotheses are claims
about your population
that you care about,
here the population is the
students at the high school.